france's interior minister the
equivalent of the home secretary came to
visit northern france here to see how
his country is trying to prevent illegal
trafficking of migrants across the
channel he visited a motorway roadblock
at the border with neighbouring belgium
and then moved on to the port hearing
stories of stowaways and swimmers
but the reason mr dominant was here was
less to do with this
and more
these were the extraordinary scenes sky
news filmed when we saw dozens of
migrants carrying a boat to the sea
in full sight of french police officers
who did nothing to stop them
the british government says it has
offered another 54 million pounds to pay
french authorities to counter these
migrant crossings
i asked mr darmanim why boats were still
getting through so easily despite all
that money
he insisted the french were investing
heavily to thwart migrants
you don't have to go far in northern
france to find the other side of this
problem a french region home to
thousands of people desperate to get to
britain
abdul rahman is here with his friends
they've all travelled from sudan
i want to go to buy a truck by
boat i don't know i try here and here
it's difficult though yes i know it's
very difficult
england very good
england respect anyone england
in the top
england
very very beautiful
and people do make journeys at all times
using thermal imaging cameras we filmed
this dinghy living a beach in the middle
of the night the three smugglers all run
off
mr dharmanan's visit had been hastily
arranged but he was in no rush ending at
the beaches from where so many boats
have departed
it's getting very dark here now gerald
dominim was supposed to have left a long
time ago instead he's still here among
the dunes
chatting to officers in the gloom now
this visit has served two purposes one
is a statement of support to all these
people but the second thing is a repost
to his critics in britain who say that
france isn't doing enough to stop
migrant crossings mr dominin says
actually it's britain that should be
doing a lot more
amid these dunes the controversy over
migration rolls on adam parsons sky news
calais